mmm mushrooms i love this one oh you
want my help oh
is it a thumbs up oh my god ew zucchini
what's going to smell really good hi
i'm going to make brownies um
i like it the bake looks amazing fresh
fluffy and good
[Music]
hi i'm hannah i'm the world's okaiest
mom and my kids are sneaky they're total
pranksters but i am
much sneakier so i want to try something
because my kids are for the most part
really good eaters but i
do know that they have some specific
foods that they really don't like so for
an entire week i'm going to try to sneak
their least favorite foods into dishes
and see how i do so wish me luck the
plan is i'm going to
tally up all of the kids collective
least favorite foods and i'm going to
try to sneak them into food for a week i
hope that at the end of this i can show
them that some foods that they thought
they hated actually taste good and if
they just don't overthink it they're
able to try it it's really important to
me to raise my kids with open minds and
so when they have a preconceived notion
about a food that they just by default
don't like it's something i want to work
on okay so something that i'm gonna do
tonight um and it's an ingredient we
what
it's an ingredient we've seen before
mushrooms if you saw me hide veggies in
my kids foods for a week you saw that
jackson has always hated mushrooms i hid
them in burgers and suddenly he loved
them well it's very hit and miss from
then on out with him and mushrooms so i
want to try again in a more creative way
so i'm going to make a chicken with a
creamy mushroom sauce all right i've got
mushrooms garlic salt and pepper cooking
i have my mushrooms and garlic and some
butter in here i'm going to add cream
and then i'm going to blend it okay i
overcrowded my pan my chicken looks
bland hopefully this helps
oh my god ew you know there's this thing
called mom brain and it's just there are
so many things going in my brain at once
and i just
things fall through the cracks i thought
i was using cream
i was using heavy whipping cream so when
i went to blend it it started to whip
so now it's just a mess it's like a soup
it's like a mushroom chicken soup i'm
gonna add some stock
i don't know what i'm doing all right
plot twist i shredded the chicken i
added a bunch of parsley because it just
looks
brown maybe it'll taste good i put this
over rice you could not tell that there
were mushrooms in this dish at all they
were completely invisible let's see what
the kids think
wyatt hair looks a little different
these days i really let my kids do what
they want with their hair so i was
letting him decide to cut it on his own
time but he saw a guy in a show with a
haircut that he liked and he asked for
it what do you think
double thumbs up you like it yep yeah
i'm glad you like it
what does it taste like is it
are you enjoying
it's just like good trying food from
another country thing
it's not another country it's just new
recipes oh
should i make it again yeah mama what
yeah i don't like
it's
it
yum yum time for another
secret hated food zucchini there's a lot
of squash slander in this house and i'm
just not having it i'm not for it i'm
going to grate this and make zucchini
fritters i am actually going to salt
this zucchini and i'm going to let it
sit
and absorb all the moisture and then i'm
going to drain the moisture from this so
i'm not getting
super soggy pancakes
and this is what i'm left with luckily
when i was prepping the zucchini the
kids were outside but i did have to work
very quickly because if they came back
in the house at any time when i'm
squeezing out shredded zucchini the
whole dish would be a moot point because
again with these foods a lot of it is
mental the second they know there's
zucchini in there they don't want it a
little pancake mix i'm just gonna do a
dash of milk
okay but these
look and smell really good i definitely
saw that there was a lot of green left
maybe i should have peeled the zucchini
but i just i feel like the skin is the
best part so i decided if they asked i
was going to tell them it was cucumber
wow this is good sour cream looks like
whipped cream i know it does huh
you like it
i was pretty surprised that they were
very receptive to the green coloring and
they ate it and they enjoyed wyatt's
enjoying because jackson's making art
henry is munching away it's really good
i tasted cucumber
yeah yeah yummy
hi
today's experiment
i'm making muffins
i'm baking muffins
nobody cares the boys just hate it for
no good reason because they love pumpkin
which is almost the same thing but the
second it's butternut squash they do not
like it i drew inspiration from my
grandma's recipe for carrot cake bars
instead of grating carrots she uses baby
food and it tastes delicious and it's
very smooth and it's very
soft and m-o-i-s-t i just added it to a
muffin like as if i was making an apple
muffin oh it looks good wow
look i like it
pumpkin flavor
it's amazing everybody loved the muffins
it was the perfect dish
okay so my spaghetti squash doesn't work
because apparently i cannot eat it or
cook it if it's sprouted on the inside
so i ordered another one in the meantime
i'm gonna give mushrooms another try
because i failed so badly with that
other recipe so i got a
really glorious mushroom this is called
a hen of the woods and i'm gonna try to
make like mushroom chips out of this i
peeled the little petals off of the
mushroom i tossed them in oil with salt
and pepper and i roasted them until they
were nice and crispy is this asparagus
it's chips what do you think honey wow
that's good
oh those are tasty try it
good mm-hmm i made my own chips
so why aren't you approved
you want some more yeah why started
shoveling them into his mouth like
shoveling them in he loved them
it looks like mushrooms it does
nothing how does it look like a mushroom
who would think that looks like
mushrooms
you know the kids had a little back and
forth on what it actually was they
settled on
they were made out of potatoes the goal
is not to trick them for the week the
goal is to find a way to have them enjoy
these foods round two spaghetti squash
so i did keep the sprouts and i'm going
to plant them he's out there burying the
squash are you putting concrete on it no
so instead of getting another spaghetti
squash i ended up buying like frozen
already spaghetti squash and i think i
have a pretty brilliant idea for this so
i'm going to make a hash brown egg bake
with half hashbrowns half spaghetti
squash because i feel like hash browns
and spaghetti squash are kind of one in
the same like texture wise and because i
was feeling so confident i decided to
add one more sneaky food into this and i
decided to try my hand at hot dogs
jackson really doesn't like hot dogs i
don't really care that he doesn't like
them he doesn't have to eat them i just
thought it'd be a fun thing to try i
decided to slice the hot dogs really
thin cut the ends off and fry it up like
bacon i did eggs cheese spaghetti squash
hash browns and a little bit of cream
and some seasonings mixed it all up
poured it into a casserole dish and
baked that all the way through
i felt super confident in this one
because visually there was no trace of
it
and the smell was delicious the texture
was amazing and i was feeling like this
was going to be a total success what do
you think jackson
um
this is delicious
it could not have gone more flawlessly
it just made my week you know when you
try something and you're not sure how
it's gonna go and everybody likes it and
you're just like
i did that
[Music]
i'm making queso so corn is very
controversial in our house because
everybody unanimously loves corn however
wyatt will not eat corn unless it's on
the cob
just something about it something about
him
his corn fantasy
has to be on the cob challenge
i blended this with a little milk
and i'm going to add it into the queso i
felt like this idea with the corn was so
good i decided to make a real for
tasty's instagram of the recipe because
i was so excited to try it but that is
where i went wrong save a few whole ones
to sprinkle in at the end so while i'm
making the real i'm realizing the
texture of this for adults
is a little bit baby food it's a little
bit too smooth i think i should add back
some more
corn
kernels wrong
this is so good
[Music]
holy moly
oh
that smells good
[Music]
the chips are good
what spectacle it's a cheesy dip hmm
kind of a big old dip
oh it's nice and cheesy i like it
here's the thing about kids the older
they get the nosier they are and the
more they notice ready
huh i do taste the corn it's amazing
um the what the corn it's amazing with
the corn you taste corn enough
how
because
it's a cheese dip
but then why so
why is there corn pieces in it
it's cheese
my sheath
and so why i didn't want it why it was
so excited to try it it definitely
tasted amazing he would have liked it
but the second jackson pointed out that
there was corn done zip
dunzo why why won't you eat it
i don't know
here come try
sit up you're a cool guy with your
glasses you're at the football game
you're having your queso
come on
there's no corn there's a chili grab it
i taste corn
[Applause]
i feel like this is something really
important to talk about and stress
actually because i think there's this
notion of a lot of family channels or
family shows um just being the parents
with a camera in their kids face at all
times we film this because it's super
fun for us and we enjoy it my kids
have their boundaries though where
they're allowed to tell me they don't
want to be on camera and i respect it
and they don't have to be so back to my
corn fail wyatt did end up trying it off
camera and he did acknowledge that it
tasted good but again the mental
notion of knowing that there are corn
kernels in there
just ruined it for him and he wouldn't
actually eat it but i did actually win
because wyatt not eating the dip meant
more for me today's food
wyatt has a real problem jackson has a
slight problem i'm gonna make brownies
with this so the recipe i did was
definitely a healthier version of a
brownie i used mashed bananas and maple
syrup instead of sugar
and i added a lot of avocado
and
basically the rest was kind of standard
brownie ingredients were you making
brownies
i'm making brownies the mistake i made
was i didn't blend the avocado i mashed
it and so once it baked i could see
little green pieces in it so i was
really nervous about that again are you
excited
[Music]
banana
i love bananas you like the brownies
that's amazing they wolfed down these
brownies
they loved them so much
and had no idea
amazing
are you almost done with your brownies
yeah i inhaled it it's so good
oh it is so good
[Music]
so did i make it through the week
without them noticing no i definitely
failed in that regard but i did succeed
in a lot of other ways because i found
some great recipes for
incorporating foods that my kids thought
they hated you know those foods i was
making yeah you know like the chicken
with rice you really liked and the
muffins and
the brownies yeah
they all had your least favorite foods
in them what
is your mind blown
[Music]
so they said that they were open to
these foods now and really i think a
huge key to food acceptance is finding a
way that you really enjoy the food and
then therefore when you see that
ingredient in a different way
you're way more willing to try it i
think that that'll carry over with a lot
of these ingredients that i tried with
the kids and i think next time they see
it they might be a lot more open-minded
except for corn corn i i give up
sorry corn you're only on the cob so
that's all for now and please message me
on instagram if you go through this too
with kids disliking certain foods for no
reason tell me how you've overcome it
and tell me if there are any foods that
i should try to get my kids to eat that
they're missing out on now if you please
excuse me i'm about to order an extra
extra large pizza extra extra mushrooms
i can't wait to share it with everyone
until next time
[Music]
you